le jouet s'universalise ce skandar 10 et
les enfants d'europe d'amérique ou
d'asie s'amuse de la même façon avec des
jouets presque semblable
[Musique]
mais ces considérations ne nous ont pas
empêchés de visiter en france quelques
ateliers du père nord morceau par
morceau la machine façonne celle qui
fermeront les yeux comme maman celle qui
pleureront comme les vraies petites
filles
celle qui marcheront peut-être avec de
presque vrai souligné
on pourra les habiller il existe
d'ailleurs une mode pour les poupées une
mode étudié par les grands couturiers de
l'infiniment petit une mode avec ses
secrets et l'on doit chaque année
modifier les habits de ses poupées et
leurs coiffures puisque la mode des
poupées évolué comme la mode féminine
[Musique]
l'industrie du jouet est l'une des
industries les plus décentralisée est
l'une des plus méconnus le jura où l'on
travaillé autrefois le bois s'est
reconverti
[Musique]
le plastique a pris le dessus comme ici
à champagnole
[Musique]
mais dans ce jura nous avons retrouvé le
dernier peut-être de ceux qui fabriquait
le soir à la veillée les bons vieux
jouets en bois
je suis monnaie vous fabriquer des
petits bateaux en bois elle a déjoué
n'est ce pas ah oui et vous vous en
fabriquer beaucoup maintenant moins que
le plastique rival il le bois et vous en
fabriquer beaucoup avant lui bosquet où
beaucoup et comment ça se passe et ça
cette fabrication
racontez moi un petit peu comment
faisiez-vous maire pascal et des femmes
pelez les bateaux oui al askari ben ali
funeka ma main c'est ça et quand est ce
que ça se passait cette fabrication ou
fabriquer sa corps dans le village en
proche du palm en hiver un mauvais pli
l'homme oui et maintenant je suis fini
quoi ça se fait presque plus pourquoi
portes que le débit donc oui et vous
êtes peut-être un des derniers à
fabriquer des petits bateaux en bois
comme ça donc jouera peut-être pas mais
il est vrai beaucoup mais vous êtes
sabotier de votre métier oui de 48 à
depuis combien de temps le père au fils
ça remonte loin pour benoît mais oui
alors ça ce sont des petits sabots pour
pour quoi ça sert à quoi qu'ils étaient
tous les bouts paix dites moi monsieur
simonet est ce que vous ne regrettez pas
un petit peu le bon vieux temps
maintenant nous sommes à l'époque de la
mécanisation 22 côté oui parce qu'on
était plus tranquille
autrefois que maintenant la vie n'était
pas la même qu'à tellement maintenant
surtout les jeunes
il nous tenait une théâtre longueur ou
trois fois on était tranquille et vous
préfériez fabriquer vos bons vieux
jouets de là le soir à la veillée
oui
certainement
[Musique]